this week marked student press freedom
day to celebrate the contributions of
student journalists all over the world
we over the past year have recognized
the work of journalists at the high
school in Pressman Florida in the wake
of the terrible shooting there and the
efforts by the students at the
University of Michigan in Ann Arbor
whose paper is now the only daily
newspaper in that city and tonight our
shout-out is for another group of
student journalists who put themselves
literally on the front lines braving
possible violence as they cover the
protests in the city of Hong Kong where
demonstrators have rallied against the
heavy hand of China at running their
City which was supposed to be
independent of Beijing the images of the
Hong Kong protesters facing off with
police had led to worldwide condemnation
of Hong Kong and authorities invasion a
live image right now what's happening
there on the streets of Hong Kong - it's
all those young haunting times you
should all toffee issue the pow pow
authorities fire tear gas and pepper
spray with the city's police
commissioner calling the demonstration
or riot and some of the most compelling
close-up footage of what's happening the
water cannons the tear gas the beatings
have come from a team of college
journalists in Hong Kong
Joanna Howe is one of them using her
iPhone and a small camera to record the
scene ready for anything we have gas
masks and helmets and let me ask you
this do you fear that you might be had
hurt covering all this because it's
become violent at some point with the
police and the protesters squaring off
I'm afraid of that and I got hurt in
November and I was I got hurt by a
rubber bullet where did you get hit and
how did it feel it felt painful it was
originally like this and then he turned
to become the bullet hits you in the leg
Joanna is part of a group of college-age
journalism students who felt the call
to record and report on what is
happening in their city despite the risk
of getting hurt or arrested their online
outlet undergrad is run by Oscar Cho why
is it important for you to be out there
it's because a man of generous in
different lines is it's not enough and
some of times the critical moment are
being captured by student generous only
and I think we are trying to like
fulfill the demand of the journalist in
different lines make takfir of being
discovered
Cho since the police called his
colleagues black journalists at least we
think we are doing illegal things that's
why he would cause deep at Turner's and
also they are thinking that we are
cooperating with the the protesters
dressed in black
that's why do you accost the black
generous Johanna ho says her only real
protection is the power of the press
label she wears proudly whenever she is
on the streets with the protesters I
guess it's hard to say it's like fun to
be different here because I guess it's
not a game I guess it's it's recharging
but it's really rewarding the same time
as I can really feel that what am i
doing is like I can't impact to the
society and joining us now in the studio
was Ariel - the producer of Brian Ross
investigates who started herself as a
student journalist in Taipei Taiwan to
see these journalists in Hong Kong
they're very brave to do this aren't
they
it was really awesome because Johanna is
only 20 and Oscar is 19 and he's now the
editor in chief of underground which is
their publication and I myself started
as a student journalist - but the fact
that they're on the frontline it's
really amazing because they're risking
their lives and is there a cultural
thing to challenge authority like that
because they could be arrested right not
really I don't think it's a culture at
the end like during the interview Joe
and I did tell us that she her parents
didn't know that she's actually
reporting on the frontline until they
saw her work
and they're still out there and their
only protection is wearing the press
vest mm-hmm yeah and the police have
been pretty brutal there haven't they
yeah I think one of the demands that
Hongkongers are trying to make it
clearer is that they want the government
to investigate police brutality and
that's been the key theme for them yeah
and she recovered from her injury the
rubber bullet hitting her in the leg yes
so far but I think that she's gonna keep
reporting and let's hope that she is
safe indeed yeah Aereo to a great peace
thanks for all your work and thanks for
being here tonight reciate very much so
that's our program for tonight thanks so
much for joining us we'll see you back
here on the law and crime Network next
week